hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play the witch's
house now a lot of you may be surprised
at me playing this because I have said
before that I didn't think the RPG Maker
games could be scary but then again you
guys have pointed out and I thought
about myself I've been playing these
pixelated organs and I've thought that
they are some of the scariest
experiences that I've ever had
so who I honestly to say that these
can't be scary I'm not saying I'm gonna
play a lot of them but I'm gonna give
this one a try because I heard a lot of
good things about the witch's house and
that it is great scary and all that good
stuff and plus as you know I am out of
town so this will be good for just a
half later on so let's get started begin
I'll hide it I have no I also have no
idea what to expect I haven't even
looked at many of these RPG Maker games
I don't think I've ever played an RPG
Maker game okay hello we seem to be in a
flower-filled we can move with the arrow
keys blah blah blah blah the kitty cat
you're up and out of May yes I am why
why do you ask why is that normal that a
cat can talk to me I really need it see
blanks house out of the force can we go
out of the forest please leave forever
and not be bothered by any of this ever
ever ever again
who is blocked by a startling huge
startling Lee huge patch of roses okay
so ooh what's that over there wait I see
some jiggly's is there a secret path
over here oh oh oh yeah found something
rusty and sharp how I got a machete umm
dangers alright um let's see movement
controls I got the movement controls I
can figure it all that I'm a smart guy
I'm a smart guy
and whoa whoa whoa wait I use the
machete on the thing you to get the
thing thumb yeah there
all right so how do we gonna well I am
machete
okay sure you're not gonna use a machete
better feed and gonna but stay away from
the forest hope to see you soon okay
fine
I won't go to the forest geez ding-dong
damn it I'll go to the frickin witch's
house oh these are the things I need to
cut okay
small batch of roses ain't no problem
for me I like how I've got still the RPG
elements I still got an HP bar that I
don't think is gonna happen any part in
playing in this okay machete
broke it broke really just after that
okay whatever stop questioning the game
markiplier okay sorry hello Luke it
again huh what is it it's weird that cat
is talking to me hmm so the way is
blocked up by roses are you gonna go in
hell yeah of course we just think I am
some time pansy I'm a strong independent
woman who don't need no man I'm gonna go
into that house and tear up yeah
I'm gonna throw a party of one
it's gonna be epic alright anyway so now
we are playing this sorry if the
resolution is great the only way I can
get it enough of a size as if I did um
in in full-screen mode and it was still
not that great so I'm sorry but I didn't
expect this to be like
[Music]
all right
now what I was expecting to me I'm just
a poor innocent little girl you
immediately murdered me is that what I'm
supposed to be expecting
let me just hang out you know you'd
stand from died don't even care don't
even can I run oh good I can run yeah
yeah yeah yeah I don't know how to save
how the hell am I supposed to be able to
do anything way is cleared yep machete
Brooks ah blah blah ah boom and we go
this stupid is stupid I don't trust any
of you I don't trust you
I don't trust you the candle flame sway
curiously look good writing
I thought I could sprint back down it
wouldn't let me ha dum dum dum
don't get hit
yeah oh you're gonna get it I'm a
cowgirl yeah
god damn you gotta be joking me take it
yes
take the damn don't listen to them
they're stupid they don't know what
they're doing
you're a strong independent woman who
don't need no tutorial I'm just a
tutorial level that's a third level over
there way to go can help you narrow I'm
just so impressed because this is
exactly what I was not expecting I
thought this was gonna be a magical
adventure of Wonders that is Oh No okay
whatever
oh I save it the cat that would have
been good to know have been very good
now before damn cab why can't you help
me I'm obviously entering a diabolical
land of Horrors maybe I just don't step
on the red that's what this sign says
come to my room
we're all really okay so don't step on
the red then you'll be fine
wait a minute yo decided I'd follow you
for laughs incidentally where the heck
you'd come out from well screw you I'm
not gonna be killed by no diabolical
evil walls what is this what is this
there's a pair of scissors on the
workbench the chain to the bench we'll
use the scissors to Calabar come on
there's nothing inside the dusty odors
its loved okay I don't like this very
much definitely different I mean I've
always said that a game a horror game
especially is like 60% of it is
dependent on sound and there's pretty
good ambience
I mean RPG maker is just like any other
game engine it's just a method to an end
all those aren't eyes that's just a
dresser daddy bear arrest against a pile
of presents taking two teddy bear I um
word war was the hat what was that
open when the house returns to normal
you mean it's not normal now which is
diary yeah sure
I was sick so no one played with me my
father and my mother didn't love me that
was it I was all you had in your diary
oh you can't write very well that's for
sure
seriously this is much why the basket
has a big teddy bear in it it's a little
bit of room left
I'll put bears in the basket let's put
the bear in the basket put in basket it
slims make it too big to fit well why
not cut them off yeah yeah yes I mama
I'm a saver in case you didn't
know this
cut them off teddy bear oh why did it
get covered with blood oh thank you
kitty you're gonna defend me right if
something comes after me right kitty
you're gonna defend me you stuffed the
teddy bear torso in the basket oh good
that's a that's a good sign hey removed
I moved you moved yeah I moved what did
you this is much creepier than I
anticipated
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh man I'm so sorry everybody that I
doubted I'm so okay I'm so sorry that I
doubted you guys I'm so sorry
that brain stew are we gonna eat brain
stew tonight is so much different than I
ever in it
wait a minute geez for me ah don't come
out of nowhere I'm a saver
I will save at every single opportunity
that I have I don't care if I've saved
two seconds ago the cook is busy lend a
hand
Oh No
haha no yeah stick your head inside
that's a good idea
oh really you're just what why did
something happen in the fireplace
fireplace nothing but sit inside at
least I'm quick I guess that's a good
thing at least I'm pretty quick hello
hmm I just squished the roach
no I'm normal earth normal come on Rosie
push okay that's I'm busy so busy
don't let hand don't do it it's a trap
this is right it's a trap okay let's
Linda no oh crap damn it I knew it I
knew it I knew I knew I knew I knew it I
knew you all knew that I knew it it's
not really surprising me I knew it okay
let's stick our head in the fireplace
Oh whizzy whizzy try their arts quest
wish okay
let's just uh read this book here dining
of the aristocrats people of ruling and
wealthy classes have long enjoyed dining
with silverware by using such hard to
clean tannery they would hire servants
to demonstrate their wealth in addition
silver utensils change color upon
contact with poison making them quite
useful I did not know that is that true
I mean I'm sure there would be some sort
of chemical reaction but not to every
poison okay so we don't do a damn thing
with senior cuts your hand we're gonna
save here and then what appeared in the
middle here the teddy bears limbs on the
ground I'll give them the teddy bear
hands that's the way he won't to take
mine actually no we have time okay hey
senior would you like some teddy bear oh
thank you I was neither than a hat show
you my oh okay just checking the never
one no funny bit
we're no funny business no funny
business again like I said saver
okay alright I'm tickled I'm tickled to
death because I did not realize that
this would actually be good like this
and and this is exactly what I meant
like I played all those pixelated horror
games and because I'm playing it it may
not seem as bad to you guys watching it
but I'm playing it right now and I've
never played anything about this or like
this so it's like a totally new
experience for me
and that terrified me that teddy bear
was like the scariest thing and it was
so perfect because they did the thing
where they drop in the and I'm like yeah
you almost got me and then you know and
it was just so good and I had no idea
than these RPG Maker games could
actually be good so this should be
really fun hope you're gonna enjoy
because I'm going to enjoy playing this
so thank you everybody so much for
watching click the annotation for more
videos that I've done and as always I
will see
you in the next video by
[Music]
Wow